bevor wir mit den haushaltsberatungen
fort fahren
müssen wir noch einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag behandeln die
fraktion der spd bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp haben fristgerecht beantragt die
heutige tagesordnung um zwei
zusatzpunkte zu erweitern
nach der schlussdebatte zum
haushaltsgesetz soll zunächst die zweite
und dritte beratung des gesetzentwurfes
zur änderung des grundgesetzes artikel
87a auf drucksache 1410 mit einer
debatten zeit von 39 minuten und daran
anschließend die zweite und dritte
beratung des gesetzentwurfs zur
errichtung eines sondervermögens
bundeswehr auf drucksache 1409 mit
ebenfalls 39 minuten debatten zeit
aufgesetzt werden die
beschlussempfehlung des
haushaltsausschusses zu den beiden
gesetzentwürfen liegen auf den
drucksachen
2090 und 2091 vor
wir zu diesem geschäftsordnungsantrag
das wort gewünscht
das ist nicht der fall dann kommen wir
direkt zur abstimmung wer stimmt
entschuldigung ich habe es nicht gesehen
also der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der linksfraktion jan
korte hatte aufgezeigt und die
bundestags präsidentin bärbel bars
verteilt jetzt allerdings als erster das
wort
für die
regierungsfraktionen der ersten
parlamentarischen geschäftsführerin der
spd katja mast das wort
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren meine sehr verehrten kolleginnen
und kollegen sehr geehrter herr
präsident stefan tschök
es ist uns eine große ehre und
ein zeichen der verbundenheit unserer
beiden länder
dass sie persönlich heute hier sind
dafür danke ich ihnen ausdrücklich im
namen der kolleginnen und kollegen von
bündnis 90 die grünen fdp und spd
unser land steht entschlossen
an der seite des mutigen ukrainischen
volkes
der von russland begonnene brutale
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine ist eine
zeitenwende
unser bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat drei
tage nach kriegsbeginn
entschlossen und präzise aufgezeigt
welche schritte jetzt notwendig sind wir
unterstützen die ukraine nicht nur
wirtschaftlich humanitär durch
sanktionen und diplomatie sondern auch
durch waffenlieferungen
damit haben wir eine langjährige
staatspraxis gebrochen
die gesamte koalition
hat mit dem sondervermögen die
konsequenzen aus dieser neuen
bedrohungslage gezogen es geht um eine
leistungsfähige und moderne bundeswehr
mit dem ziel der landes und bundes
verteidigung
denn
denn der krieg in der ukraine hat uns
auch schreckliche art und weise vor
augen geführt wir müssen unsere freiheit
schützen in dieser neuen situation mit
neuen wegen und deshalb ist es gut dass
wir beim sondervermögen unser
bundeskanzler und die gesamte regierung
von anfang an eine breite unterstützung
hier im parlament
gesetzt haben unter einbeziehung von cdu
und csu
das war eine mutige entscheidung das war
eine richtige entscheidung in eine
entscheidung die unser land voranbringt
sie ist gut denn parallel geht es darum
dass wir ohne abstriche weiter in
sozialen zusammenhalt in unserem land
investieren denn die menschen schauen
heute auch darauf ob wir den weg des
fortschritt weiter gehen und das tun wir
wir beschließen heute endlich endlich
endlich endlich den mindestlohn in einer
hilf und zwölf euro für sechs millionen
menschen unserem land und das erste
lenzen paket mit einer band
seit 30 jahren nicht mehr bei der
verbesserung für
erwerbsminderungsrentner endung hätten
die bürgerinnen und bürger im land
erwarten von uns dass wir jetzt handeln
es geht um einen starken und
handlungsfähigen staat auch sozialstaat
dass wir darum die insel und soldaten
ihre reisen zu verschieben
deshalb werden wir die gesetze zum
sondervermögen
traumas zwingen ich finde sie kommen sie
bitte zum schluss spielte sie
mein letzter satz
[Musik]
sie müsse zur geschäftsordnung lesen
der andere projektion der aussetzung des
sondervermögens und des errichtungs
gesetzes zuzustimmen ja das ist eine
geschäftsordnungsdebatte und der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der
unions-fraktion er hatte sich
zwischendurch tatsächlich bärbel bas
beschwert dass katja mast doch zur
geschäftsordnung reden möchte und nicht
inhaltlich zu sondervermögen oder
anderen themen also es geht darum ob
heute
über das sondervermögen beraten und das
ganze hier auf die tagesordnung gesetzt
wird
gern korte jetzt für die linke
nicht getan haben und es ist auch eine
regierung ist eine irreführung der
öffentlichkeit zu sagen auch wir grüßen
herzlich demokratischen
parlamentspräsidentin haben das fraktion
die linke ist aber eine irreführung so
zu tun als ob es hier umgehen würde
jetzt konkret der ukraine zu helfen sei
eine irreführung des parlaments würde
zum zweiten festhalten dass wir im
ältestenrat in der vorletzten sitzung
uns interfraktionellen noch mal
bekräftigt habe insbesondere sie dass
wir in haushalts wochen keiner anderen
anträge außer haushaltsberatung führen
würden und jetzt schlagen sie vor dass
wir mal eben so das grundgesetz in
dieser woche ändern das ist absolut
unglaubwürdig was sie dort gesagt haben
möchte daran erinnern dass der bundestag
am montag seine fraktions und
gremiensitzungen haben dort waren sie
nicht in der lage den anderen fraktionen
mitzuteilen weil sie dort im
hinterzimmer irgendwie noch mit der cdu
um die lust oder was weiß ich dass wir
das hier machen am dienstagmorgen um 8
uhr war eine interfraktionelle pdf runde
angesetzt die von ihnen abgesagt worden
ist und erst einige stunden später haben
sie den fraktionen mitgeteilt dass wir
diese woche das grundgesetz ändern
wollen 100 milliarden euro aufrüstung
sondervermögen hier beschließen wollen
so geht es überhaupt nicht
in relation zu setzen
dass mein relation zu setzen möchte ich
zur geschäftsordnung weiter aus wenn sie
haben vorgeschlagen heute die
grundgesetzänderung plus 100 milliarden
euro sondervermögen in 78 minuten
debatte hier abzuhandeln heute
nachmittag ich möchte um das buy in
relation zu setzen was 100 milliarden
euro bedeuten im beratungsverfahren hier
im bundestag folgendes sagen 100
milliarden entsprechenden etwa dem
umfang folgender einzuplanen innen
justiz finanzen wirtschaft und
klimaschutz ernährung und landwirtschaft
digitales und verkehr auswärtiges amt
jugend und familien das ist in etwa acht
einzuplanen umfang von 100 milliarden
euro liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
wenn ich daran erinnern darf haben sie
uns diese aus halb zwölf stunden
beratungszeit in dieser woche genommen
bei der einbringung zwölf stunden macht
zusammen 24 stunden plus hunderte von
stunden die die haushälterin und
haushalt die berichterstatter im
haushaltsausschuss und jeweils
zehntausende von euro diskutiert und
gefälscht haben diese relation stimmt
überhaupt nicht wieder voll und ganz
aber es fällt einem um das jahren
allerseits dieser
denn in der tat der tanz medium eine
zeitenwende die sie offenbar ja begrüße
nicht weniger aber es ist eine
zeitenwende in der tat der vielleicht
schon sagen und das dann mal in 78
minuten abgehandelt ist der sache nicht
angemessen und zum anderen will ich ja
frau strack-zimmermann die die große
militär sachverständige sie werden
wahrscheinlich für 200 milliarden am
besten schon am mittwoch setzen kann ich
nicht einfach drauf eingehen ich rede
hier schon verfahren und sophie dieses
verfahren nicht und im übrigen ist
völlig unseriöse parlamentsberatung 400
milliarden euro hier jetzt also für die
ausrüstung raus zu ballern und nicht
einen deckungsvorschlag zu machen die
das ganze eigentlich finanziert werden
soll und ich sage ich ihnen dass ihr auf
kosten des sozialstaates gehen das sind
kosten von bibliotheken der pflege und
alles andere mehr weil sie nämlich
gleichzeitig die schulden werden sie
nächstes jahr wieder einsetzen werden
das müssen sie sich insbesondere von den
sozialdemokratischen freunde tragen
lassen so ein unsauberes schmuddel
verfahren machen wir nicht denn es geht
in der tat hier um eine zeitenwende
vielen dank
jan korte war das parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der linksfraktion die
linksfraktion ist nicht nur gegen das
100 milliarden euro sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr sondern ist auch das hat
ja jan korte deutlich gemacht gegen
dieses verfahren auch ist auch dagegen
dass das ganze heute beraten und
beschlossen werden soll dass also der
antrag der linken jetzt thorsten frei
erste parlamentarische geschäftsführer
der unions-fraktion
auch präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
es ist richtig dass diese beiden
tagesordnungspunkte heute auf die
tagesordnung gesetzt werden deswegen
wird die cdu csu fraktion sowohl der
aussetzung der beiden
tagesordnungspunkte nämlich der des
beschlusses über das bundeswehr
finanzierungsgesetz wie auch die
zugrunde liegende grundgesetzänderung
zustimmen beides der aufsetzung und in
der sache aber es ist nicht angemessen
so zu tun als ob der zweck alle mittel
heiligt und es war die erste
geschäftsordnungsdebatte die ja nicht
zur geschäftsordnung sondern zur sache
war man kann so auch mit
minderheitenrechten im parlament nicht
umgehen ich will das mal vernünftig
herleiten und die vernünftige
herleitungen lautet folgendermaßen der
herr bundeskanzler hat dieses
sondervermögen in seiner
regierungserklärung am 27 februar
angekündigt er hat es skizziert wir
haben beide gesetze sie haben beide
gesetze hier im bundestag im april
eingebracht wir hatten anfang mai die
expertenanhörung zum thema das heißt wir
hatten tatsächlich die situation uns
über wochen hinweg mit einem thema das
uns in den letzten wochen mehr als alle
anderen beschäftigt hat intensiv zu
beschäftigen
das haben auch wir als cdu csu fraktion
gemacht und ich gehe mal davon aus dass
das andere auch getan haben wir haben
uns am vergangenen sonntag mit den
koalitionsfraktionen auf eine lösung
geeinigt ich will das mal ganz offen
sagen wir hätten dafür keine drei monate
gebraucht denn wir haben uns ja nicht
nur durchgesetzt sondern wir haben im
grunde genommen nur durchgesetzt was der
bundeskanzler am 27 februar gesagt hat
nicht mehr und nicht weniger
und dass sie uneinigkeit kinder fragt
inter koalition haben hat dazu geführt
dass es so lange gedauert hat und dass
wir es jetzt hals über kopf in dieser
woche machen müssen wir machen es und
ich sage ihnen auch warum weil wir vor
gewaltigen herausforderungen stehen weil
wir tatsächlich eine zeitenwende erleben
weil es um milliarden von euros für die
bundeswehr geht aber es geht nicht nur
um die bundeswehr es geht nicht nur um
die verteidigungs und
bündnisfähigkeit unseres landes es geht
auch um die sicherheit unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten wir möchten
planungssicherheit für unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten deswegen müssen
wir es züge machen wir machen es unter
einhaltung der geschäftsordnung das ist
wichtig zu betonen wir haben an keiner
stelle form und frist verletzt aber ich
möchte in richtung der
koalitionsfraktionen auch sagen wir
haben sie ausgereizt die möglichkeiten
der geschäftsordnung und ich möchte
wirklich darum bitten dass wir das in
zukunft nicht mehr tun sondern dass wir
die möglichkeiten für eine breite
parlamentarische debatte insbesondere
dann wenn es um solche kernthemen geht
auch tatsächlich haben in richtung der
linken möchte ich sagen dass ich für die
frage inwieweit wir es in dieser woche
behandeln und inwieweit genügend zeit
dafür besteht durchaus verständnis habe
der ehrlichkeit halber herr kollege
korte muss man sich ich dazu sagen ihnen
geht es glaube ich weniger um fristen
ihnen geht es weniger um die frage ob
man mehr zeit für die meinungsbildung
hat sie sind dagegen sie haben es auch
deutlich gesagt sie sind heute dagegen
und sie werden auch in vier wochen
dagegen deswegen glaube ich können wir
das guten gewissens heute so entscheiden
herzlichen dank
thorsten frei erster parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer der unionsfraktion die
union wird ja benötigt um dieses
sondervermögen im grundgesetz zu
verankern denn für diese
grundgesetzänderung wird eine
zweidrittelmehrheit benötigt jetzt für
die fw fraktion deren parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer
baumann
frau präsident sie meine damen und
herren unsere armee unsere soldaten
werden seit jahrzehnten
vernachlässigt unterfinanziert kaputt
gespart und sie alle hier sind daran
beteiligt egal ob cdu spd fdp oder grüne
sie alle haben sie alle haben unsere
soldaten auf die tödliche einsätze
geschickt ohne entsprechende ausrüstung
wir von der afg sieht die einzigen die
sich immer für eine starke bundeswehr
eingesetzt haben keine fraktion hier im
parlament hat je mit heißem herzen
tieferer inbrunst für eine bessere
ausrüstung unserer bundeswehr gekämpft
meine damen und herren das will ich hier
noch mal deutlich sagen
unsere soldaten brauchen diese 100
milliarden wahrscheinlich eher noch mehr
in dieser geschäftsordnungsdebatte geht
es nun aber darum ob die vorliegende
gesetzesvorlage wie sie aus den
ausschüssen kommt überhaupt
entscheidungsreif ist neben nur weil die
maßgebende sitzung des
verteidigungsausschusses
die sollte vorgestern um 7 uhr beginnen
die den abgeordneten laden aber keine
finalen gesetzesvorlagen vor niemand
konnte sich einarbeiten prüfen irgendwas
beurteilen abends um 18 uhr wieder eine
sondersitzung aber endgültige dokumente
immer noch nicht da dann nach über einer
stunde plötzlich erstmals das ganze bild
ganz plötzlich nicht nur seitenlange
gesetzestexte wirtschaftspläne
beschaffungs listen über kampfflugzeuge
kriegsschiffe u boote hubschrauber
panzer dazu noch ein neues gremium von
den vorher nie die rede war und dann
wurde sofort abgestimmt
sofort jede fraktion hatte lediglich
eine minute zeit um stellung zu nehmen
über ein paket das zuvor nur
ampelkoalition und die cdu gesehen
hatten die sie zuvor in hinterzimmern
ausgekungelt hatten und das war ein
beschaffungs wert von 100 milliarden
euro einmalig in der geschichte der
bundeswehr meine damen und herren das
ist so unseriös das haben unsere
soldaten nicht verdient
wir müssen diese beschaffungs pläne
solide prüfen lassen sie uns deshalb die
entscheidung in die kommende
sitzungswoche verlagern cdu-abgeordneten
sich auch schon vorgeschlagen gehabt
nach jahrzehntelanger vernachlässigung
unserer armee unserer soldaten fällt
dieser kurze aufschub nicht ins gewicht
nehmen sie die vorlage heute von der
tagesordnung meine damen und herren wenn
sie dazu nicht bereit sind wenn sie dazu
nicht bereit sind wenn sie heute über
dieses konvolut gleich eine abstimmung
erzwingen wollen die mehrheit dazu haben
sie ja geben wir vor diese
undurchsichtige untragbare situation
gestellt unseren abgeordneten die
entscheidung frei
während baumann war das für die afg
fraktion
wir liegen jetzt keine weiteren
wortmeldungen zur geschäftsordnung vor
dann kommen wir zur abstimmung
wer stimmt für diesen aussetzungsantrag
der tagesordnungspunkte das ist die spd
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen fdp und
cdu csu fraktion wer stimmt dagegen die
fraktion die linke und die fdp fraktion
enthaltungen sehe ich nicht damit ist
der auf sitzungs antrag angenommen